[Musique]
antoine phénomène soit repensé ordre on
commence avec une un fox qui nous vient
des états unis autour de migrants
supposée oui absolument et tout part de
cette vidéo vous l'apercevez ici on y
voit des hommes alignés en file devant
ce qui ressemblait trou qui attend deux
cas qualifiés par l'auteur du tweet d'un
hôtel vidéo largement reliés par des
comptes pro trump à l'image de celui que
je vous montre en ce moment même on y
voit donc la vidéo en question sur
également sur un autre camp pluie
totalement ouvertement pro train vous
voyez il s'appelle tram crusaders
carrément et bien lui il dit qu'il dit
et se comptait bien que ce sont des
migrants illégaux âgés de 18 à 25 ans et
on leur donne selon lui est bien des
cartes de crédit une chambre d'hôtel
tout ça
la vidéo elle l a bien été tournées en
floride à mettre landes exactement elle
est même devenue rapidement virale un
élu républicain l'a d'ailleurs partagé
son nom c'est anthony sabatini lui aussi
le reprend l'information qui relayait
par le tweed d'origine que je vous ai
montré au début lui voilà encore une
fois ce sont des migrants illégaux ils
demandent bien sûr leur expulsion
immédiate encore plus surprenant voire
même plus inquiétant audrey c'est que
cette vidéo a provoqué des mobilisations
spontanées de militants anti migrants
souvent supporters de donald trump les
médias locaux sont sans eau paris
c'était notamment le cas à orlando et
notamment ce média local telemundo 31
une chaîne d'information locale du coup
a couvert l'événement une est une
petite dizaine de personnes avec des
drapeaux américains étaient présentes
ainsi que des drapeaux confédérés mais
aussi des pancartes menaçante sûr que
l'on peut voir dans ce reportage et que
je vous livre l'une d'entre elle dit
clairement clandestins méfiez vous ici
nous portons des armes après la rumeur
d'orléans la rumeur d'orlando met donc
dans les faits évidemment ce ne sont pas
des migrants illégaux mais oui vous en
doutez pas du tout ce sont des biens des
mexicains mais venus travailler sous le
régime des vis du visa 10 h 2a ne sont
donc pas venues illégalement aux états
unis tout ce sont des ouvriers agricoles
venus fournir
leurs bras leurs services donc
temporairement à une entreprise locale
là où ça va encore plus loin c'est que
le maire de la ville lui même ou dont
vont travailler donc ses ouvriers
agricoles merde à pop cas c'est le nom
de cette ville a dû lui-même réagir
l'entreprise dé were nurserie donc qui
les emploient a fait appel d'un cassé
les travailleurs dans ce qu'ils
appellent une nursery de plantain d'une
certaine manière pour à pouvoir donc
prendre soin de ses bébés planté signe
de plus de l'ampleur de la polémique là
où ça va encore plus loin c'est que le
consulat du mexique à orlando lui même a
dû se fendre d'un communiqué pour
expliquer que c'est sans mexicains
étaient présents sur le territoire
américain de manière légale donc sous le
système de visas h-2a ce visa qui permet
à des travailleurs étrangers de venir
donc temporairement travailler sur le
sol américain donc en conclusion pas de
migrants illégaux vous l'aurez bien
compris mais bien des travailleurs
mexicains une petite centaine en tout
cas cette affaire illustre bien audrey
la sensible question migratoire aux
états unis notamment chez les plus
conservateurs et notamment les militants
train de piste alors voilà pour cette
infraction ce qui est pas là dessus vous
vouliez nous parler d'un drapeau oui une
info que c'est un peu un peu plus légère
cette fois histoire de se quitter sur un
ton un peu plus joyeux celle d'une photo
en particulier vous l'apercevez elle a
été relayée sur facebook mais aussi par
ce compte twitter qui s'interroge est ce
que c'est c'est vrai alors qu'est ce
qu'on voit sur cette photo est bien on
voit un drapeau qui est entouré les
petites particularités je sais que ça
n'a pas échappé à vos yeux avisés ma
chère audrey vous voyez bien c'est un
drapeau allemand mais il est un peu
particulier c'est le drapeau de la rda
de l'allemagne de l'est on le reconnaît
au compas au marteau et à l'épi de blé
le commentaire en dessous de la photo
est dit les olympiques de pékin alors
est ce que cette photo a été prise à
l'occasion des jo de pékin qui se
déroule en ce moment bien évidemment non
grâce à une simple recherche d'image
l'inversé vous en avez désormais
l'habitude d'en avant et autres on peut
retrouver et bien l'origine de cette
photo a été postée en 2019 parce qu'on
te facebook ici l'utilisateur dit bien
c'est le drap pour ressusciter à
l'occasion de la coupe du monde de
biathlon de canmore canada c'est très
précis et ce n'est pas un hasard car
cette compétition commémorait les jeux
olympiques d'hiver de 1988 à calgary
toujours au canada à l'occasion les
drapeaux de l'époque avait donc sortent
elles étaient donc de sortie
d'où le drapeau de la r d alors et le
média allemand souhaitait d'ailleurs en
parler de cette petite information le
média bildt d'ailleurs c'en était fendu
d'un petit article nos confrères de la
fp de leur côté étaient également
présents sur place et ils ont pu
confirmer tout ça et d'ailleurs pour la
petite histoire le drapeau sachez qu'il
est toujours suspendu à cet endroit a ça
en donc non la rda n'a pas été réussie
cité à l'occasion des jo de pékin en
hommage au communisme d'une certaine
manière il s'agit simplement d'un
hommage pure et simple donc un petit
acte de nostalgie merci beaucoup antoine
fenaux merci à vous d'avoir suivi cette
de mire d'information